OK, I'm finding myself very annoyed by a portion
of the left that thinks anybody being cautious
about the polling for Donald Trump versus
Joe Biden is doing some kind of reverse gaslighting
or concern trolling.
I am here to tell you guys right now.
Cut it.
We have to stop it or we're going to lose.
Donald Trump can easily end up winning reelection.
Now, when I say this, I'm not saying Trump
is definitely winning right now despite the
polling.
I'm not saying the polling is wrong.
What I am saying is that a small change between
now and November could easily end up with
Donald Trump winning the Electoral College
while still losing the popular vote.
Every time I point this out, I get more and
more people e-mailing me saying, David, stop,
reverse gaslighting us.
You're making us think Biden will lose.
So that we go out and vote when in reality,
Biden has this locked up.
First of all, Joe Biden does not have this
locked up.
And I'm going to present the facts to you.
Let's do it step by step.
Number one, national polling trend lines.
Yes.
Joe Biden right now is winning the national
polls by an average of seven.
But two days ago it was eight, and two months
ago it was 10.
So the lead is shrinking for Joe Biden now.
OK.
You might say fine.
Joe Biden's winning by seven instead of 10.
But seven is a huge lead in the popular vote.
Well, that's true.
But let me remind you that on this day in
2016, you go back and look at the polling,
Trump versus Hillary.
August 27, 2016.
Hillary was winning by six point three.
So the difference between today and 2016 is
zero point seven points.
Biden's plus seven right now.
Hillary four years ago today was plus six
point three.
And Trump won electorally in 2016.
I don't know about you, but zero point seven
points is not exactly something that makes
me feel particularly confident.
If it comes down to zero point seven percentage
points in November 3rd, comparing to 2016
to 2020.
Like, for example, Hillary won the popular
vote by two point one.
If Biden wins by 2.8, he can still lose.
He can still lose.
So this is not a joke.
This is not gaslighting.
This is not concern trolling.
And pollsters are noticing 538.
Nate Silver tweeted about it yesterday.
He tweeted, quote, Biden's Electoral College
win probability down a bit to 70 percent after
some mediocre polls for him this morning.
He had been hovering around 73 percent.
So not a big shift, but worth a quick Twitter
thread.
And Nate Silver went on later in the same
thread to say, quote, Biden has gotten some
not so spectacular swing state polls lately.
His lead in Florida is down to five point
four and Pennsylvania to five point eight,
which remain the most likely tipping point
states.
Not bad, but the Electoral College popular
vote gap would appear to be widening a bit.
And then later yesterday, Nate Silver tweeted,
quote, Fundamentally, the fundamentals are
improving for Trump.
The economy is getting better, although that
could be threatened by congressional inaction.
Cold cases are going down, although that could
reverse itself at pretty much any time.
This is exactly the case I've been making
for two to three months now.
Presidential prognosticator Allan Lichtman
recently said all of his qualitative indicators
point to Biden.
It still looks OK for Biden.
So what do you want to take a chance on that
and then add to this voter suppression that
we know they will do?
The funny business with the post office that
they are doing already.
Early voting starts soon.
You should go do it.
Find your plan.
Are you going to vote in person?
Are you going to wear, you know, three masks
and a hazmat suit and vote in person?
Are you going to get an absentee ballot and
send it in by mail?
Are you getting an absentee ballot and dropping
it off?
Have a plan.
We must operate under the assumption that
Trump could win any state by one vote.
And based on that, every single person should
be voting and assuming nothing.
This is not concern trolling.
These are the numbers.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.